la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal et
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
d'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement la séance je
vous le rappelle est retransmise sur
Public Sénat et notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et aussi au respect du
temps de parole je donne la parole
immédiatement à notre collègue Patrice
Joly pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous
connaissez aujourd'hui les difficultés
que rencontre nos élus locaux avec la
crise sociale que nous vivons générant
des attentes fortes de notre population
tout cela dans un contexte de défiance
vis-à-vis des institution qui rejaillit
sur les élus locaux et qui se traduit
aujourd'hui par de la violence verbale
et physique ceci est un tolérable dans
ce contexte nos élus sont en première
ligne en créant de nouveaux services
souvent pour compenser les défaillances
des services publics relevant jusqu'à
présent de l'État on pense en
particulier à la santé aujourd'hui ces
mêmes élus voire leur marge de manoeuvre
financièrement fortement réduite par
d'une part l'évolution rapide des
dépenses liées à l'inflation ainsi qu'au
revalorisation nécessaire des salaires
et par d'autres parts une évolution plus
faible de leur recette Miss sous tutelle
de l'État est en jeu la question de la
préservation des capacités
d'investissement des collectivités
locales qui représentent je vous le
rappelle 70% de la vestiment public
comment pourront-elles renforcer leur
engagement dans les transitions si des
aides existe le reste à se large est de
plus en plus insoutenable est également
en jeu notre cohésion sociale et
territoriale dont la Commission
européenne elle-même en mai dernier a
rappelé l'importance pour la dynamique
de développement de notre pays tout
entier monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
dès aujourd'hui nous assurer d'une
évolution des deux questions de l'État
au moins égal à l'inflation à compter du
prochain budget et à une remise à plat
pardon rapide des dotations en vue de
renforcer leur péréquation tout aussi
urgent de la remise à plat de la
fiscalité locale pour laquelle
aujourd'hui les collectivités ont perdu
toute autonomie pourtant affirmé par la
Constitution et trouver un nouveau panel
de ressources fiscales
pour garantir ce principe à plusieurs
reprises au Sénat et en particulier à
notre groupe avec la proposition de loi
constitutionnels de notre collègue Eric
kerrouch doute dernier a formulé des
propositions pour que je sois discuter
chaque année une loi de financement des
collectivités locales et éviter que les
collectivités ne soient des variables
d'ajustement monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire si sur ce point la
position du gouvernement peut évoluer je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre
délégués en charge des comptes publics
monsieur Attal sur le ministre avait la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Joly j'ai
régulièrement l'habitude de dire qu'il
ne faut pas opposer l'État aux
collectivités locales et je vous
remercie puisque dans votre question
vous avez insisté sur le fait que l'État
a besoin évidemment des collectivités
locales pour les services qu'elles
apportent à la population pour la part
qu'elles ont dans l'investissement
public dans notre pays et donc dans la
transition écologique et les
collectivités locales ont besoin de
l'État évidemment pour intervenir en cas
de crise pour venir les soutenir c'est
ce qu'on a fait l'an dernier avec le
filet de sécurité d'ailleurs je vous
annonce que 400 millions d'euros ont été
dépensés au titre du filet de sécurité
inflation pour 2022 je vous rappelle que
l'an dernier quand je faisais des
estimations autour de 430 millions
d'euros beaucoup de doutais du fait que
ce filet trouve son public et que
l'argent soit dépensé ça a été le cas et
j'aurais l'occasion de donner les
détails dans quelques jours pour que
vous puissiez le voir mais c'est plus de
3000 communes PCI qui ont pu bénéficier
du filet de sécurité que vous avez voté
et je vous rappelle que vous avez décidé
et voté une réédition de ce filet de
sécurité en 2023 avec des critères
assouplis là aussi pour accompagner les
collectivités locales les plus
fragilisées par la hausse des prix liés
à la crise de l'inflation mais on le
voit elles ont évidemment besoin de
pouvoir investir et on a besoin qu'elle
puisse investir c'est pour ça que
l'engagement de stabilité de
sanctuarisation de la DGF qui a été pris
par le Président de la République en
2017 a été tenu et qu'on a même été plus
loin puisque je vous rappelle que cette
année on a abondé la DGF de 320 millions
d'euros ce qui fait 90% des communes ont
vu leur DGF augmenter et je sais que
dans votre département de la Nièvre ça
également été le cas nous avons tenu cet
engagement nous avons augmenté le
concours aux collectivités locales nous
avons créé le fond vert nous allons
rééditer le fond vert conformément à
l'annonce de la première ministre sur
les investissements massifs pour la
transition écologique pour répondre à
votre question sur le prochain PLF non
monsieur le sénateur nous n'allons pas
faire d'économie et amputer la DGF
contrairement à ce qui a pu être fait
par ailleurs à l'époque entre 2012 et
2017 par le gouvernement que nous
soutenions que nous soutenions tous les
deux à l'époque je suis honnête pour le
dire nous ne ferons pas les économies
sur la DGF qui avait pu être faite à
l'époque de la présidence de François
Hollande merci
avant de donner la parole
au président Roquier je souhaite saluer
notre collègue le président du groupe
RDC qui a décidé de ne pas briguer un
nouveau mandat en septembre prochain
sénateur du Lot depuis 2011
vice-président de notre commission des
finances il préside depuis 6 ans le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen et contribue à faire
vivre le plus rallisme politique cher à
notre institution est particulièrement
cher au groupe RDSE qui est l'héritier
de groupe qui ont façonné la République
il est attaché à cette idée du Sénat
fait de laïcité et d'ouverture je
remercie vraiment au nom de tous les
collègues et au nom du Sénat pour son
engagement au service de nos territoires
notamment au territoire ruraux dont il
s'est fait le porte-voix
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole
merci le poème c'est le président merci
mais chers collègues je vais dans
quelques semaines vous m'avez dit que
c'est le président parti à la retraite
et ma dernière question d'actualité au
Gouvernement portera sur les retraites
et plus précisément sur les prévisions
du corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites les prévisions sont toujours
en exercice difficile surtout
lorsqu'elle concerne l'avenir affirmé
Pierre Dac et le corps ne dérange pas à
la règle juin 2017 le corps assure que
la France peut envisager l'avenir sans
régime de retraite avec une sérénité
raisonnable mais c'est moi plus tard il
cherche la vie et prévoit une explosion
de déficit 2003 après une première
tentative avorté le Président le
gouvernement prévoyant difficile 13
milliards d'euros en 2030 programme une
nouvelle réforme des retraites avec un
départ repoussé de 62 à 74 que dit le
corps son président affirme que les
dépenses de retraite ne dérape pas sont
relativement maîtrisés et globalement
stabilisé même à long terme pour ant
laisser penser qu'il n'y aurait pas de
problème de financement et peut-être pas
besoin de réforme
la réforme sera finalement votée au
Sénat et forceps à l'Assemblée nationale
avec le 49-3 et suscitera manifestation
colère violence le 22 juin dernier
changement d'analyse le dernier rapport
du corps assure que la réforme ramènera
pas les tirs financiers en 2030 et
prévoir au contraire un retour durable
et déficit dès l'an prochain voilà pour
la première ministre que pensez-vous de
ces diagnostics apparemment
contradictoire du corps sachant qu'en
matière de politique publique
l'efficacité des décisions dépend de la
véracité du diagnostic pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Jean-Claude Roquier je
regrette tout comme vous qu'une instance
comme le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui avait été créée pour
rassembler tous les acteurs et partager
des constats communs sur le financement
de nos retraites n'aient pas pu
pleinement jouer son rôle ces derniers
temps je regrette en particulier que ces
travaux aient pu prêter à toutes sortes
d'interprétations et d'expression
éloignant ainsi le corps de sa mission
originelle de mon côté monsieur le
Président requier comme vous et avec mon
gouvernement nous nous en tenons à ce
qui est écrit
que nous disait le corps au moment de la
Réforme que notre système était
déficitaire et que dans aucun scénario
même les plus optimistes nous ne
pouvions retrouver l'équilibre d'ici
2030 et que nous dit le corps
aujourd'hui il confirme à nouveau qu'il
y aurait eu des déficits importants sans
la réforme et qu'elle permet de les
réduire considérablement d'ici 2030 ce
dernier rapport du corps confirme aussi
comme nous le disions que notre réforme
augmente le niveau moyen des pensions et
que les retraités modestes sont les
premiers bénéficiaires de cette hausse
monsieur le Président Jean-Claude
requier alors qu'il s'agit de votre
dernière question d'actualité au
Gouvernement je voulais à mon tour sur
un plan plus personnel vous remerciez
saluez votre engagement et celui de
votre groupe vous êtes ici un sénateur
écouté un président de groupe respecté
un défenseur inlassable de la laïcité
engagée pour votre territoire pour les
élus pour nous compatriotes notamment
dans la ruralité vous êtes à l'image de
votre groupe un partisan du dialogue et
des solutions un artisan des consensus
et des compromis je tenais à vous
souhaiter le meilleur et à vous
remercier pour tout le travail accompli
je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci de la
première ministre je pense qu'à l'avenir
il faudra clarifier le son du corps et
politiquement je concluré avec Alfred de
Vigny le son du corps le soir au fond
des bois
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Raymonde
pour ces monstres le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre près d'un Français sur 6
déclare ne pas manger à sa fin dans un
contexte de crise inflationniste des
prix alimentaires par essentiel du
budget des plus modestes les Restos du
Coeur constatent cet été une
augmentation de 25% des Français qui ont
recours à l'aide d'alimentaire aucun
territoire n'est parié et au fil de vos
réformes les publics s'élargissent
travailleurs pauvres jeune famille
monoparentale retraités enfants de moins
de trois ans avec plus de 16% cet hiver
l'inflation déstabilise aussi
l'équilibre budgétaire des associations
d'aide l'achat des produits alimentaires
et d’hygiène devient trop onéreuse pour
les associations qui reçoivent moins de
dons alimentaires de moindre qualité
obligé de prélever
sur leur fonds propres pour répondre à
la demande l'année prochaine si aucune
mesure n'est prise le budget alimentaire
des du coeur aura presque doublé en deux
ans 40% des épiceries solidaires ont dû
réduire la quantité des produits et
parfois l'accès à l'épicerie ont dû
baisser le seuil du reste à vivre pour y
avoir accès Emmaüs refuse cinq personnes
par semaine et par communauté de façon
inédite face à l'influence certains
restos du cœur ont du stopper des
inscriptions et ont mis en place des
listes d'attentes les associations vous
tirent la sonnette d'alarme car face à
ses effets ciseaux elles ne pourront
plus nourrir et accompagner
convenablement
pardon les personnes les plus démunies
le filet de sécurité des associations se
fragilisent que prévoyez-vous enfin dès
aujourd'hui pour restaurer leur capacité
à faire face à l'extrême pauvreté
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
personnes handicapées madame darrieussec
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice poncée oui
penser mon je pardon vous l'avez dit
effectivement l'inflation a fragilisé
une partie de nos concitoyens et
notamment les plus modestes les chiffres
actuels montrent le début d'une
éclaircie mais
ce n'est pas bien sûr suffisant quoique
la mise en place dans la grande
distribution à la demande du
gouvernement d'un trimestre
anti-inflation pour garantir aux
consommateurs des prix préférentiels
pour un ensemble de produits du
quotidien amène déjà à une consommation
peut-être plus aisée mais également le
gouvernement agit vous le savez pour
contenir la hausse des prix de l'énergie
45 milliards 46 milliards d'euros
dépensés pour la revalorisation
anticipée de 4% des prestations
complétées au 1er avril pour atteindre
5,6% à 90 et en matière alimentaire ce
dont vous parlez qui est essentiel il y
a eu un renforcement exceptionnel des
moyens des associations d'aide
alimentaire les crédits de l'État ont
ainsi triplé sur 2022 pour atteindre 156
millions d'euros cela a permis notamment
d'affecter un urgence 10 millions
d'euros d'aides alimentaires à
destination des étudiants cet hiver et
d'apporter des la réponse spécifique aux
outre-mer la lutte du gouvernement
contre la précarité alimentaire se
concrétise aussi dès 2023 par le
programme mieux manger pour tous dotés
de 60 millions d'euros pour cette
première année d'amorçage et qui
permettra de financer des paniers et des
chèques verts et solidaires sur ces 60
millions d'euros 40 millions en
vocations à financer des actions
nationales et le travail mené par le
ministre Jean-Christophe Combes avec les
18 associations agréés flèche
actuellement ses crédits et ce travail
touche à son but et permettez-moi madame
la sénatrice de tirer mon chapeau à tous
les bénévoles qui travaillent dans ces
associations d'aide alimentaire qui font
un travail absolument extraordinaire
merci
vous parlez de 2022 je vous parle
d'aujourd'hui les associations vous
proposent une augmentation du fond
d'aide alimentaire durable ou du Fonds
européen comme lors de la crise de la
pandémie un réacte de est attendu de
vous ce sont des mesures d'urgence mais
plus durablement madame la ministre
portait les minimas au seuil de pauvreté
et ce sans condition
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Colette mélo pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
et je reviendrai sur son cas après
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues
c'est pour moi l'occasion de poser ma
dernière question et je voudrais
yassocier mon collègue Jean-Pierre de
Cole qui comme moi a choisi de ne pas
solliciter de nouveaux mandats madame la
Première ministre mon engagement dans la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire et
le cyber-harcèlement et sans faille et
il y a six semaines j'interpellais une
fois encore monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale suite au décès
tragique de l'Insee quelques mois à
peine après celui de Lucas madame la
Première ministre vous annonciez début
juin vouloir faire de la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire la priorité absolue
de la rentrée et vous l'avez rappelé
vendredi dernier nous saluons évidemment
cette annonce comme le futur déploiement
d'un grand plan d'action contre un fléau
d'une grande violence mi-juin une heure
de sensibilisation au harcèlement devait
avoir lieu dans tous les collèges
qu'elles ont été les retours en 2021
j'avais proposé une mission retenue par
notre groupe et qui a réuni 23 sénateurs
ce qui a permis la publication d'un
rapport réunissant 35 préconisations
deux années ont passé le harcèlement
continue de faire des victimes malgré
les mesures mises en place comme le
programme PHARE et dans mes déplacements
j'ai pu constater les différences de
mobilisation des équipes éducatives il
est urgent d'agir et vous savez
pertinemment qu'un grand plan mettra du
temps à se déployer pourtant des mesures
simples aborder le sujet lors des
pré-rés pour sensibiliser l'ensemble des
enseignants et toute la communauté
éducative présenter le droit existant et
les numéros d'aide dans le carnet de
correspondance évoquer le sujet lors de
la première réunion des parents d'élèves
sont pour ne citer qu'elles des mesures
qui pourraient être réalisées dès les
premiers jours de septembre alors madame
la Première ministre quelle mesure
concrète seront effectivement mises en
œuvre dès la rentrée
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Colette Melot vous
m'interrogez sur un sujet qui vous tient
à cœur je le sais qui a été un des fils
rouges de votre engagement en tant
qu'élu et sur lequel vous avez écrit un
rapport en effet important ce sujet la
lutte contre le harcèlement à l'école
j'y tiens moi-même tout particulièrement
le harcèlement est insupportable c'est
la violence et la bêtise qui s'abattent
sur un jeune le poursuive à l'école
jusque chez lui sur les réseaux sociaux
et peuvent le pousser à se couper des
autres à la dépression et parfois
l'irréparable
aujourd'hui comme vous madame la
sénatrice j'ai une pensée pour l'Insee
Lucas channel ou Dina qui ces dernières
années ont préféré mettre fin à leurs
jours plutôt que de continuer à
supporter cela
c'est inacceptable et révoltant c'est
pourquoi j'ai voulu que la lutte contre
le harcèlement soit une priorité absolue
pour la rentrée 2023 depuis 6 ans
beaucoup d'actions d'été engagées
notamment grâce au programme de
prévention d'alerte et d'intervention
phare et à la mobilisation de tous les
acteurs mais nous devons aller plus loin
encore et c'est pourquoi j'ai réuni mes
ministres la semaine dernière
spécifiquement sur le sujet pour mieux
prévenir les risques avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale papengai nous
avons décidé de déployer le programme
phare dans tous les établissements dès
la rentrée scolaire pour protéger les
élèves et s'assurer que la parole se
libère un coordonnateur sera nommé dans
chaque établissement pour répondre
efficacement à toutes les situations et
prendre en compte l'impact des réseaux
sociaux l'ensemble des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse et des forces
de l'ordre seront sensibilisés aux
enjeux du harcèlement scolaire et en
ligne j'ai demandé à mon gouvernement de
travailler et de bâtir autour du
ministre de l'éducation nationale un
plan interministériel pour la rentrée il
devra permettre une meilleure prévention
en sensibilisant et effectivement dès la
rentrée les élèves et en
responsabilisant les parents il
permettra de mieux détecter le
harcèlement de mieux accompagner les
victimes et d'avoir un suivi plus
rigoureux des auteurs nous devons enfin
mieux coordonner les acteurs simplifier
faire connaître d'abord et simplifier
nos dispositifs d'écoute et de prise en
charge
mesdames la sénatrice il s'agit je le
sais de votre dernière question dans
cette émission et je veux rendre hommage
à votre travail à votre volonté d'agir
et saluer la marque que vous laisserez
au Sénat après plus de 18 ans de mandat
j'en profite pour saluer également
madame la présidente Catherine Deroche
madame les sénatrices Laurence Cohen
Françoise Ferrat messieurs les sénateurs
gatelins le nez Guenet et Bernard
Fournier madame
madame la sénatrice Colette mélo
j'évoquais votre engagement contre le
harcèlement vous pouvez compter sur nous
pour continuer à mener ce combat prendre
toutes les mesures qui s'imposent pour
éviter les drames veillez à la civilité
dans tous les échanges et protéger les
enfants je vous remercie merci
moi je voudrais aussi m'associer à ce
que vient de dire madame la Première
ministre chers collègues mélo depuis
2004 vous êtes engagés au Sénat engagé
d'abord au sein de la commission de la
culture avant de rejoindre la commission
des affaires sociales et comme
vice-président de la commission des
affaires européennes ce sujet du
cyber-harcèlement avec lequel vous venez
d'échanger avec la première ministre a
toujours été vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel pour vous permettez-moi d'y
associer celui qui était associé à votre
question Jean-Pierre de Cole qui député
puis c'est la terre a représenté ici le
département du Nord avec une petite
tendance particulière pour la Flandre je
dois le dire tiens Jean-Pierre et
rapporteur aussi d'une mission
d'information et Laurence Cohen ça va
lui parler ce qui me permet de la saluer
sur la pénurie de médicaments des 2018
et la commission d'enquête créé
l'initiative de votre groupe la rappeler
je voulais vraiment m'associer à ce que
vous avez dit sur ces deux collègues
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Catherine de roche
la dernière séance et oui de cette
session extraordinaire et l'occasion de
saluer les collègues qui ont pris la
décision de ne pas se représenter et je
dois dire que comment ne pas évoquer
l'empreinte vous avez marqué à la
commission des affaires sociales
en tant d'abord que rapporteur du PVF
esss pour la branche maladie et ensuite
comme présidente porteur de valeurs avec
cette dimension particulière en Juine
faite de douceur et de détermination et
oui et de détermination et et d'autorité
vous avez toujours conduit la commission
avec courtoisie et efficacité succédant
à l'un Milon et la conduisant vers ces
rivages qui n'étaient pas toujours le
calme de la Loire mais parfois un peu
les crues de la Loire quand vous aviez
des choses à dire je voudrais vraiment
vous remercier aussi pour ce que vous
avez fait pendant cette période il y
associer les collègues si complexes du
covid dans lequel votre commission a été
au premier rang parlons aussi de la
situation de l'hôpital vraiment je
voulais vous remercier chers présidente
au nom du Sénat tout entier
[Applaudissements]
madame la
merci merci monsieur le Président et
merci à chacun et chacune ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé bien évidemment et monsieur le
ministre depuis un an votre feuille de
route était chargée nous avons fait le
point la semaine passée en commission en
effet surtout ces chantiers qui sont
ceux de des urgences de la pédiatrie de
la psychiatrie la Réforme hospitalière
en matière de gouvernance ou
tarification de prévention
des Colocs et des tables rondes récentes
organisées au Sénat ont montré néanmoins
des retards administratifs importants si
je pense à l'innovation en cancérologie
par exemple ou à la prise en charge de
la douleur chronique mais plus monsieur
le ministre demeure chez les soignants
une perte de sens dans leur métier et
chez les Français en général et chez les
patients une perte de confiance c'est
comme si quelque chose dysfonctionnait
c'était brisé voire n'était plus dans la
politique sanitaire
selon la tradition de l'humanisme
médical je rappellerai cette formule du
docteur Porto au sortir de la guerre la
médecine c'est la rencontre d'une
confiance celle du patient qui rejoint
librement une conscience celle du
médecin or nous voyons bien qu'il y a de
réelles difficultés dans ce domaine donc
vous qui représentez la puissance
publique comment comptez-vous
réenchanter cette rencontre
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la santé et de la
prévention Monsieur François Braun
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrice messieurs sénateur
madame la Présidente de roche merci de
l'honneur que vous me faites de poser
votre dernière question au gouvernement
j'en profite pour rendre hommage au
travail que vous avez conduit au sein de
la commission des affaires sociales j'ai
rencontré toujours une écoute et des
dialogues extrêmement apaisés avec des
confrontations d'idées mais qui ont
chaque fois enrichi et enrichit les
nombreux textes que nous avons à
discuter ensemble vous avez
effectivement une douceur et une
autorité naturelle qui permette que les
débats se déroulent dans les meilleures
hospices alors concernant la relation
soignants soignée bien sûr vous avez
raison cette relation est essentielle
dans le contact entre le patient et le
soigner entre le pardon le soignant et
le soigner et très certainement cette
crise sanitaire avec le flot
d'information très certainement cette
accès facile à l'information aussi des
contra conditions qu'on a pu entendre
chez les professionnels de santé on fait
que comme vous le dit très bien cette
confiance est érodée au cours du temps
or rien de plus important que cette
relation qui donne du sens dans ces
métiers du soin et qui est très
importantes pour évoluer les nouvelles
technologies le numérique ne doivent pas
au contraire nous éloigner de cette
relation doivent en tout cas sont là en
mon sens pour nous donner plus de temps
et nous rapprocher de ces discussions
auprès des professionnels alors vous le
savez j'ai mis l'éthique au centre du
principe de la refondation de notre
système de santé rapidement trois
exemples pour vous montrer que nous
allons ce sens le premier le déploiement
des CNR santé comme l'a voulu le
président de la République qui a ceci
systématiquement les soigner donc aux
citoyens à côté des élus et des
professionnels de santé pour justement
donner la parole à ceux que l'on
n'entend pas assez souvent le
déploiement des patients partenaires ou
des patients experts qui est quelque
chose que le ministère accompagne et
souhaite continuer à développer et enfin
la mise en place des indicateurs de
perception de la qualité des soins par
les patients eux-mêmes largement
développé dans les pays anglo-saxons
nous avons encore du retard à rattraper
dans ce sens et c'est un des éléments
clés du nouveau financement de la
sécurité sociale encore une fois merci
pour cette année passée à échanger sur
notre système de santé
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors moi je
vais faire un vœu puissiez vous
pardonnez-moi l'expression familière
secouer le cocotier de la lourdeur
administrative que ce soit
l'administration de la santé et j'y
ajouterai Bercy et puis n'hésitez pas
surtout à vous appuyer sur les rapports
du Sénat ce qui permettrait de gagner du
temps car nous sommes souvent
précurseurs et ça urgentiste que je
parle vous savez combien la notion de
temps est précieuse en matière de soins
et j'ajouterai que ce conseil vaut pour
l'ensemble du ministère merci madame la
Présidente
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
folio pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de la Défense il y a quelques
jours j'étais avec notre collègue de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN le
député allemand Marcus Faber tout près
de la ligne de front à Ukraine pour
notre deuxième visite en quelques mois
lors de nos rencontres avec les soldats
de la 47e brigade équipée des puissants
et flambants neufs chars lourds léopal
léopard 2 ou avec la 37e brigade de
marine récemment dotée de nos années
antiques amx-10rc nous avons constaté
deux choses les préparatifs de la vraie
contre-offensive battent leur plein les
soldats Ukrainiens sont fatigués certes
mais déterminées plus que jamais l'enjeu
est clair aujourd'hui les défenses
russes sont solides et structurées il
s'agit pour le moment de taper ici ou là
sur ce mur pour voir les points de
faiblesse afin ensuite d'y concentrer
les efforts pour créer une brèche qui
changera la nature de ce conflit nous
sommes à la croisée des chemins
enlisement jusqu'à épuisement de nos
opinions publiques souhaités par Poutine
ou percer qui sera un pas décisif vers
la victoire des forces de la liberté et
de la démocratie afin de réussir cette
manœuvre l'Ukraine à urgent besoin de
plus d'avions de chasse de charlour de
système de défense entière d'artillerie
de moyenne de déminage de missiles
courtes et moyennes portées si les
canons César que nous avons livré joue
pleinement leur rôle les vieux
amx-10rc sont complètement inadaptés
madame la ministre nous devons changer
de braquer si la récente décision de
livraison de missiles scalp est une
bonne nouvelle quid pour la suite en cet
instant décisif allons-nous être à la
hauteur du soutien qu'attendent et
mérite nos alliés
ukrainiens
quand vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État chargée l'ancien
combattant madame mirales vous avez la
parole madame la ministre merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Sénateur folio
tout d'abord je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser le ministre des Armées
Sébastien Lecornu qui est en train de
rentrer du sommet de l'OTAN à Vilnius
pour se rendre à l'Assemblée nationale
qui prononcera sur les conclusions de la
CNP sur la loi de programmation
militaire et qui d'ailleurs comme le
Sénat demain le fera je vous sais très
engagé sur le sujet de l'aide à
l'Ukraine vous connaissez la situation
pour vous y êtes rendu à plusieurs
reprises comme vous le savez depuis le
début de la guerre la France s'est
engagée à soutenir l'Ukraine dans sa
légitime défense contre l'agression de
la Russie ce soutien militaire répond à
des critères clairement définis par le
Président de la République une aide
utile une aide qui ne conduise pas à
l'escalade et une aide qui
n'affaiblissent pas la défense de la
France
une des spécificités de notre soutien
militaire et que nous fournissons des
capacités complètes incluant non
seulement les équipements mais aussi la
formation et les solutions de
maintenance c'est que c'est ce que nous
avons fait pour nombre de matériels qui
ont fait leur preuve sur le terrain et
apporter un avantage opérationnel à
l'Ukraine notamment les canons César les
mystales crotale les sambt pour la
défense aérienne ainsi que les blindés
vabes ou encore des chars des chars
légers
mx10rc demandez d'ailleurs par les
Ukrainiens dans ce cadre le président de
la République a annoncé hier à Vilnius
que la France allait livrer de nouveaux
missiles permettant des frappes dans la
profondeur il s'agit de missiles scalp
tiré depuis des aéronefs avec une portée
de 250 km environ ces missiles dont nous
sont d'une grande précision en vocation
à être utilisée exclusivement à
l'intérieur du territoire U il porteront
un avantage significatif à l'Ukraine
dans son cadre contre la sa
contre-offensive les discussions entre
chef d'État Vinus porte également sur
les engagements supplémentaires que nous
pouvons prendre pour garantir la
sécurité de l'Ukraine pendant que les
conflits continuent et que les
perspectives pardon d'adhésion à
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN à terme ces
discussions sont encore en cours à cette
heure et des annonces auront lieu dans
la foulée je vous remercie
merci
je vais donner maintenant la parole
notre collègue Laurence Cohen c'est la
crise du val-de-mars depuis 2011 qui
elle aussi je le disais tout à l'heure
décidé de fabriquer un nouveau mandat je
ne pourrais pas de ne pas évoquer sur
l'engagement à la commission des
affaires sociales mais aussi à la
délégation des droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes sur les sujets sociétaux
elle a été elle est très engagée je
pense récemment la question de la santé
des femmes au travail à la pénurie
médicament je l'évoquais mais aussi au
travail qui a été fait par la délégation
sur la lutte contre la pornographie et
je voudrais saluer ces convictions très
très fortes me souviens d'une visite que
nous avons fait ensemble à Gustave
Roussy d'ailleurs avec la présidente de
la commission je voulais la remercier
vraiment au nom du Sénat dans la
diversité de nos convictions ce qu'elle
représente
madame la Vice-Présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales merci
monsieur le Président à l'initiative de
mon groupe la
commission médicament a rendu son
rapport qui a été adopté dans la
pluralité de nos sensibilités politiques
rapporteur je tiens à saluer
chaleureusement la présidence Sonia de
la provoté et l'ensemble des membres de
la commission pour le travail accompli
dont 36 recommandations visant à
combattre ces pénuries exponentielles et
structurelles les industriels
pharmaceutiques Français envisagent en
plus d'abandonner la production de près
de 700 préparations pharmaceutiques dont
des médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs chaque fois ce sont les
conditions de soins qui sont remises en
cause c'est donc la santé des malades
qui est menacée dans des plaisent aux
industriels le responsabilité est grande
monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous rétablir notre souveraineté
sanitaire et industrielle mis à mal par
la course à la rentabilité
quels sont parmi nos recommandations
celles que vous allez mettre en œuvre en
urgence
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice lance Cohen merci de me
réserver également votre dernière
question au gouvernement ça me permet de
saluer votre engagement au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales des
discussions parfois animées que nous
avons pu avoir pas toujours du même avis
mais toujours de façon extrêmement
respectueuse les uns des autres ce qui
fait j'en suis certain la grandeur de
notre démocratie et de cette possibilité
de discussion alors concernant les
tensions de médicaments c'est un
phénomène vous le savez qui est mondial
c'était d'ailleurs le seul sujet de la
dernière réunion des ministres de la
Santé de l'Union européenne phénomène
mondial sur lequel sur l'autorité du
Président de la République et de la
première ministre nous activons
l'ensemble des leviers dans le cadre
d'un plan de lutte contre les pénuries
plan pour lequel votre rapport va être
une aide très importante aux décisions
que nous aurons à prendre mais d'ores et
déjà je me souviens quelques points déjà
l'élaboration de cette liste de 450
médicaments dit essentiel qui est une
liste je le redis qui est une liste
vivante qui est amenée à évoluer mais
qui nous permet de faire une
cartographie très précise de la
production de ces 50 de ses 450
médicaments depuis l'usine jusqu'à
l'étagère de la pharmacie le soutien a
une initiative belge au niveau européen
avec plus de 20 autres pays soutient sur
une politique de pénurie de médicaments
à l'échelle européenne de souveraineté
européenne mais également de
transparence sur les prix de
transparence sur les productions et des
laboration aussi d'une liste essentielle
dans le cadrechious France saluer les 1
milliard d'euros d'investissements des
laboratoires en France justement pour
travailler sur cette souveraineté
industrielle et puis avec mon collègue
Roland Lescure dans le cadre de la
relocalisation annoncée par le président
de la République de 25 médicaments dans
un premier temps puis des 25 civils dans
les années à venir enfin les travaux qui
sont menés sur les approvisionnements
particulièrement innovants de
médicaments vous voyez nous sommes
mais comme je vous l'ai dit les
conclusions de votre rapport viendront
augmenter nos possibilités de réaction
dans le cadre de ce plan pénurie je vous
remercie
monsieur le ministre j'espère
effectivement que notre rapport va vous
inspirer parce que comme nous le
soulignons il y a un manque
d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement une communication brouillée
et en fait pas de pilote dans l'avion
vous avez réamorcé effectivement les
relocalisations c'est bien mais il faut
raisons garder sur 106 projets financés
par le plan de relance et France 2030
seul 18 concerne une réelle
relocalisation et 5 un médicament
stratégiques réorienter les aides
publiques et incitations fiscales vers
la production en France de médicaments
essentiels 710 millions d'euros de
crédits impôts recherche version 2021
sans contrepartie il faut un minima
retrouver la maîtrise publique sur la
production d'un certain nombre de
médicaments essentiels en restaurant
notamment la capacité de façonnage de la
Pharmacie centrale de la PHP depuis
plusieurs années je plaide vous le savez
avec mon groupe pour un pôle public du
médicament en France et en Europe
changer ce modèle économique qui
engendre des pénuries ayez ce courage le
médicament n'est pas une marchandise
c'est un bien commun de l'humanité
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue André gatolin c'est vraiment la
journée des départs
puisque André gatelat lui aussi pas
souhaité renouveler de son mandat et
c'est la tour des Hauts-de-Seine depuis
2011 vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense et
de la commission des affaires
européennes nous avons tous en tête la
mission d'information sur les influences
étatique
extra-européennes dans le monde
universitaire qui appelle la mieux
protéger notre patrimoine scientifique
et nous liberté académiques face aux
risques d'ingérence venant des tailles
sujet toujours d'actualité merci à André
gatelin
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre chargé de la
transition numérique monsieur le
ministre il y a maintenant 10 ans le
Sénat publié un excellent rapport de
notre collègue Catherine Morin de
saillie intitulé l'Union européenne
colonie du monde numérique ce rapport à
l'époque fit coulait beaucoup d'encre et
reste encore aujourd'hui une référence
même si dans le domaine des technologies
numériques notamment à depuis
considérablement évoluer à l'époque
l'espace numérique était dominé par
quelques géants américains de l'Internet
et l'Union européenne pénètent à jeter
les bases d'une régulation du secteur ce
n'est que trois ans plus tard que fut
enfin adopté le fameux rgpd règlement
général sur les données personnelles
monsieur le ministre la semaine passée
le Sénat a publié un nouveau rapport
fruit de 4 mois de travaux intenses une
commission d'enquête emmenée par nos
collègues Claude malurey et Michael
Valley portant sur le réseau Tik Tok son
exploitation des données et sa stratégie
d'influence mes chers collègues ces
conclusions sont édifiantes malgré
l'adoption de nombreuses législations
européennes et nationales visant à
encadrer le développement souvent
anarchique des réseaux sociaux nous
constatons que certains acteurs au
premier rang desquels le très puissant
Tik Tok sont loin sont très loin de se
plier aux exigences de la Loi pire cette
entreprise serait particulière fait
preuve d'une telle opacité et ces liens
avec le régime de Pékin apparaissent si
étroit que nous proposons dans cette
commission sa suspension pour des
raisons de sécurité nationale si à
l'horizon du 1er janvier 2024 elle ne se
conforme pas à une série d'exigences
légales et de transparence minimale
quant à son fonctionnement et à sa
gouvernance alors Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle est
l'approche du gouvernement à ce sujet et
quels sont les mesures que vous entendez
prendre afin que tik token enfin se
conformer au droit national et au droit
européen je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Jean-Noël barreau
ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et les
télécommunications sur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs permettez-moi à
mon tour de rendre hommage à l'action
car mené André gatelin tout au long de
ces deux mandats au sein de cette
vénérable institution vos travaux
monsieur le sénateur et notamment ceux
qui ont porté sur le numérique et
l'intelligence artificielle font honneur
au Sénat et font honneur à la République
permettez-moi ensuite de saluer
l'engagement des membres de la
commission d'enquête sur Tik Tok son
initiateur est rapporteur claudemanuret
sont présidents Michael Valley et tous
ses membres comme la première ministre a
eu l'occasion de le dire la semaine
dernière ce rapport fera date dans
l'histoire du contrôle parental et du
contrôle parlementaire et pour l'avenir
de la régulation des grandes plateformes
numériques le Gouvernement partage le
triple constat de ce rapport Tik Tok
enfin les règles européennes sur la
protection des données personnelles
Tik Tok avec ses al le rythme conduit à
l'enfermement et l'isolement de ces
utilisateurs notamment les plus
vulnérables et je pense aux enfants cela
soulève des questions de santé publique
et d'ordre public parfois et
troisièmement TikTok du fait de ces de
son milliardet de télécharge de
téléchargement et de ses liens avec la
Chine soulève des questions de
géopolitique auxquelles il nous faut
rester particulièrement vigilant sur la
question des données personnelles j'ai
demandé à Tik Tok de nous fournir un
état des lieux de leur avancement sur la
conformité aux règles européennes et je
m'engage à venir présenter devant les
membres de la commission d'enquête avant
la fin de l'année cette cette avancement
ce n'est pas une faveur que nous
demandons à Tik Tok c'est une exigence
absolue que nous posons s'agissons de la
toxicité des algorithmes Tik Tok devra
comme toutes les grandes plateformes
se soumettre aux obligations de
transparence d'audits algorithmiques de
prise en compte des risques ces
plateformes font peser sur la santé de
leurs utilisateurs comme sur la sécurité
publique
dès le 25 août prochain entrée en
vigueur du Règlement sur les services
numériques vous le voyez le Gouvernement
partage l'esprit des auteurs de ce
rapport c'est d'ailleurs dans ce même
esprit qu'il a présenté un projet de loi
qui vise à réguler et sécuriser l'espace
numérique qui a été adopté la semaine
dernière à l'unanimité du Sénat
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole notre collègue
Bernard Fournier
qui
a décidé lui aussi de ne pas se
représenter Bernard Fournier c'est 26
ans de mandat de sénateur de la Loire
ce gaulliste ce gaulliste convaincu
depuis ces années étudiante sur les
bancs de l'IGP un homme attaché à la
mémoire et au patrimoine il a été
représentant du Sénat à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de la mer Noire
observateur attentif d'une région au
cœur de l'actualité et grand spécialiste
de nos relations avec la Roumanie je
voulais le remercier pour tout cela
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'Éducation
nationale dimanche sur radiologie vous
élevons du cœur des préoccupations qui
devrait être celle du ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous vous êtes
vous êtes violemment pris à deux médias
dont le tort sans doute et de ne pas
toujours être le relais de ce que vous
pensez de ce que vous prenez à court
d'arguments et sans aucune démonstration
vous avez brandi l'ultime mise en cause
ces deux médias seraient d'extrême
droite n'a plus radicale ces médias se
feraient même selon vous du mal à la
démocratie et vous nous dites votre
inquiétude pour nos valeurs
républicaines l'heure est grave
comment Monsieur le Ministre avez-vous
pu vous laisser aller à une telle
facilité comment pouvez-vous fuiger un
média parce qu'il ne pense pas comme
vous que faites-vous de la liberté des
journalistes à s'exprimer que
faites-vous de la liberté et
d'indépendance de la presse en jauvant
la thème contre ces médias vous faites
preuve d'un terrible mépris vis-à-vis de
tous ceux spectateurs et auditeurs qui
les regardent et les écoute
plutôt que de vous en prendre la liberté
d'expression il serait plus judicieux
que vous apportiez de vraies réponses à
l'effondrement du niveau scolaire au
déclin de la France dans les classements
internationaux à la flambée des
atteintes à la laïcité aux difficultés
de recrutement des enseignants ou encore
au sentiment légitime d'abandon qui les
anime monsieur ministre ne pensez-vous
pas que nos enfants et le personnel de
l'éducation nationale mérite mieux de
leur ministre que des anathèmes et des
propos
inutilement polémiques je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre que l'éducation nationale des
de la jeunesse Monsieur pavendai Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Fournier il y a la liberté de
la presse à laquelle je suis aussi
attaché que vous mais il y a aussi la
liberté d'expression ce sont deux
libertés qui sont essentielles
et à ce titre il est de mon droit le
plus strict de donner un point de vue
sur la ligne éditoriale d'une chaîne de
télévision il ne s'agit pas de censurer
qui que ce soit si monsieur le sénateur
vous aviez écouté mon interview dans sa
durée sur les grands chantiers de
l'éducation nationale vous m'auriez
interrogé sur la parentalité
l'implication des parents dans la square
dans la scolarité des enfants vous
m'auriez interrogé sur l'orientation des
élèves avec la découverte des métiers
vous m'auriez interrogé sur la réforme
du bac et les pistes de travail pour la
réforme du troisième trimestre vous
m'auriez interrogé sur la question du
niveau en français et l'introduction de
critères formel dans l'évaluation des
copies du bac en orthographe et en
syntaxe ceux qui passent par un
renforcement des disciplines
fondamentales c'est ce que nous faisons
en classe de 6e avec l'heure de
renforcement et de soutien en français
et en mathématiques vous m'auriez
interrogé sur l'augmentation des
professeurs des personnels d'orientation
et d'éducation à partir de la rentrée
des augmentations significatives que
l'on n'a pas connu depuis 30 ans vous
m'auriez interrogé sur l'autonomie des
établissements avec le Conseil national
de la refondation voilà monsieur le
sénateur les sujets sur lesquels vous
auriez pu m'interroger des sujets quand
même plus essentiels que la dérive
extrême droitière d'une chaîne de
télévision
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Fournier
la parole est à notre collègue Angèle
prévu pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vent
violent orage destructeur qui aurait pu
prévoir depuis des années les
scientifiques du GIEC et du Haut Conseil
pour le climat nous alerte sur
l'intensification des phénomènes
climatiques extrêmes ce n'est que le
début qui aurait pu prévoir valise et
recluent en 1864 dans la terre détruite
par l'homme je cite quel que soit la
liberté conquise par notre intelligence
et notre volonté propre nous n'en
restons pas moins les produits de la
planète attachés à sa surference comme
d'un perceptible animalcules nous sommes
emportés dans tous ces mouvements et
nous dépendons de toutes ces lois qui
auraient pu prévoir alors d'un vote à
minima sur la restauration de la nature
au Parlement européen la dure réalité
implacable c'est l'effondrement des
populations d'insectes le 29 juin
dernier l'État a été à nouveau condamné
le tribunal administratif de Paris à la
suite de requêtes de plusieurs
associations en juin la première
ministre et les ministres compétents de
prendre toutes les trop utile de nature
à réparer le préjudice écologique et
prévenir l'aggravation des dommages en
rétablissant la cohérence du rythme de
diminution de l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires la réparation du
préjudice devra être effective au 30
juin 2024 au plus tard oui il y a
préjudice écologique résultant je cite
de la contamination généralisée diffuse
chronique et durable des eaux et des
sols par les pesticides en 2021 la note
scientifique de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques de notre collègue Annick
Jacquemet sur laquelle s'appuie
notamment la décision du tribunal faite
inédit dans le
mentionne qu'un tiers des espèces
d'insectes sont menacés d'extinction
dans le monde alors qu'ils sont à
maillon essentiel de la chaîne
alimentaire et conclue les pesticides
constituent une menace particulièrement
importante pour les insectes en raison
de leur utilisation intensive depuis des
dizaines d'années et déréglementation
inadaptées pour évaluer les risques
qu'ils font encourir vous n'avez plus le
temps de tergiverser tous les signaux
sont au rouge la situation appelle une
action urgente ambitieuse et forte que
proposez-vous pour enrayer ce désastre
pour vous répondre la parole dès que tu
as au ministre de la transition
écologique Christophe Béchu la cohésion
des territoires j'avais la parole
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je m'autorise un salut
particulier à une femme à laquelle vous
avez rendu hommage puisque j'ai eu le
plaisir de siéger à ses côtés même de
faire liste commune ce qui montre à quel
point les convergences sont parfois
possibles dans notre monde dans une
autre vie madame la sénatrice prévienne
madame la sénatrice Préville vous avez
évoqué le jugement du tribunal
administratif de Paris du 29 juin
et puisque vous avez cité certains
aspects j'aurais aimé que vous alliez
jusqu'au bout
que dit le tribunal administratif de
Paris il pointe le fait que malgré les
engagements pris en 2009 dans le cadre
du Grenelle de l'environnement sur la
diminution des pesticides en quantité ça
n'est pas ce qui s'est passé entre 2009
et 2013
ce qu'on appelle les nombres de doses
unités qui est la manière de calculer le
nombre d'hectares couvert par des
pesticides a augmenté de 13%
ensuite dans la période de 2013 à 2018
nous avons à nouveau augmenté de sorte
que depuis 2009 ça n'est pas une baisse
mais c'est une hausse de 20% en moyenne
des pesticides et que du tribunal il dit
que malgré la baisse
constaté en 2018 et enclenchée depuis
cette date et qui s'est poursuivi
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la baisse n'a pas
été suffisante pour corriger le
préjudice écologique l'honnêteté aurait
justifiée que vous indiquez que cette
bascule elle a commencé elle a commencé
en nombre 10% de recul sur les
pesticides vendus depuis 2018 elle a
commencé en risque puisque sur les CMR 1
qui sont les pesticides les plus
cancérigènes c'est 93% de baisse depuis
2018 qu'est-ce que nous allons faire
poursuivre cette accélération faire en
sorte dans le cadre du plan écofito en
particulier tel qu'il a été défini par
la première ministre de ne pas se
contenter d'attendre des rapports
d'experts mais de regarder par
anticipation les molécules susceptibles
de basculer dans le champ de
l'interdiction pour lancer les
programmes de recherche
à partir d'un triptyque simple pas
d'interdiction sans solution mais pas de
solution sans financement et sans effort
pour trouver ces solutions merci de
votre question
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
renon le globe pour le groupe les
républicains voilà
[Applaudissements]
ministre mes chers collègues les images
de la France qui brûle on fait le tour
du monde
qu'il s'agisse d'immeubles incendiés de
mairie de commissariat attaqué au
mortier qu'il s'agisse de nos
centres-villes saccagées partout sur la
planète dans tous les journaux de
télévision télévisés à travers le monde
on a vu ces images
et tous s'interroge mais qu'en est-il de
la France nos 3 millions de compatriotes
qui vivent à l'étranger ont été
interrogés dans les pays où ils vivent
la France est-elle toujours la France
de la même manière
les chefs d'État étrangers les
gouvernements à l'étranger interrogent
nos ambassadeurs
qu'en est-il de la France que devient ce
pays et donc ma question est la suivante
madame la ministre
quelles sont les directives quelles sont
les messages que vous envoyez à nos
ambassadeurs à travers le monde pour
répondre à ces gouvernements étrangers
est-ce que vous leur dites de répondre
comme l'a fait le président de la
République
on va y réfléchir
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'Europe
madame Laurence Baule vous avez la
parole madame la ministre merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Sénateur
legleux d'abord je vous prie d'excuser
Catherine Colonna qui est également à
l'OTAN au sommet de l'OTAN avec le
président
permettez-moi d'abord rappeler que ces
violences qui ont suivi la mort
dramatique de Naël sont absolument
éteinte il est inacceptable de détruire
des écoles il est inacceptable de
détruire des mairies des médiathèques
des biens publics
les forces et des commerces les forces
de l'ordre ont réussi à ramener le calme
très rapidement dans le strict respect
de la loi et en limitant le nombre de
blessés maintenant tout le gouvernement
a beaucoup communiqué y compris à
l'étranger sur les mesures qui ont été
prises pour établir l'ordre républicain
sur notre public pardon sur notre
territoire nous ambassades ont été
informés elles ont rassuré elles ont
beaucoup parlé si bien que comme la
rappeler la ministre du Commerce du
tourisme il n'y a pas eu d'annulation il
n'a pas eu de modification de séjour il
n'y a pas de baisse de la fréquentation
en revanche en revanche je crois qu'il
ne faut absolument pas être dupe du
cynisme et des mauvaises intentions de
certains pays qui n'hésitent jamais
devant une instrumentalisation ou de la
désinformation et là je vais être très
clair
dans certains pays les images des
événements sont utilisés au profit de la
propagande des régimes autant internes
que contre notre pays et nous avons
systématiquement répondu à ces
malveillances notamment aux propos
azerbaïdjanet turc ou iraniens
les leçons de ces pays je suis sûr que
vous en conviendrez prêtez à sourire
s'il n'y avait pas autant de problèmes
de droits de l'homme en leur sein
enfin je crois qu'il faut rappeler que
c'est un problème qui est aussi propre à
beaucoup de démocratie qui comme le
Royaume-Uni en 2011 eux aussi un an
avant les Jeux Olympiques la Suède le
Danemark ont vécu de tels événements et
sont extrêmement compréhensifs et
partageurs des solutions qu'ils ont mis
en place également je vous remercie
monsieur Lele
madame la ministre vous vous défaussez
au lieu de regarder la réalité en face
dans un an le monde entier va avoir les
yeux rivés sur la France
alors il faut cesser de réfléchir
maintenant il faut passer à l'action et
il est temps de restaurer l'autorité de
l'État dans notre beau pays pour que
l'an prochain quand le monde entier aura
les yeux rivés sur notre pays nous
puissions tous ensemble être fiers des
images que la France enverra à
l'international merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Françoise Ferrat pourrait elle
aussi
c'est
la dernière question
après un mandat qui a commencé en 2001
comme sénateur de la Marne notamment
investi sur les enjeux ruraux et
agricoles au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques je voudrais citer
mes chers collègues le rapport qu'elle a
fait avec Henri Cabanel et rapport sur
la détresse et les suicides en
agriculture qui doit nous amener me
semble-t-il à réfléchir collectivement
sur la situation du parti de notre
population qui a parfois le sentiment
qu'on ne prend pas suffisamment compte
ce qu'elle représente pour notre pays
vraiment je vous la remercier pour cet
engagement dans notre assemblée
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole madame la sénatrice
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues des constats persistants
témoignent de la baisse des compétences
des élèves français en mathématiques et
de désinfection pour les cursus
scientifiques
sachez que 80% des enfants en
Grande-Bretagne et en Allemagne ont des
activités scientifiques en dehors de
l'école nous n'en avons que 8% en France
la culture scientifique est pour tous
les citoyens pas seulement pour les
scolaires les Français reconnaissent
avoir confiance en la science les sujets
scientifiques réchauffement climatiques
nucléaire pandémie vaccin alimentent la
réflexion et le débat mais aussi la
controverse et la suspicion
quelle place pour la science dans nos
sociétés abreuvées d'information 24
heures sur 24 les enjeux mondiaux à
venir sont interdépendants de la science
et des avancées technologiques
l'ensemble de la population doit
disposer des codes et des clés pour
comprendre les enjeux fondamentaux qui
vont changer nos habitudes et nos
certitudes de plus la confusion entre
l'opinion et l'effet scientifique
constitue une menace pour la démocratie
et pour nos sociétés un rapport de
l'UNESCO sur la science précise que les
sciences la technologie et l'innovation
ont la capacité de changer la donne pour
relever pratiquement tous les défis
mondiaux les plus urgents méditer cela
mes chers collègues ainsi la puissance
industrielle de la France que nous
appelons de nous veut progressera avec
ses connaissances c'est pourquoi la
culture scientifique de se développer à
l'école mais aussi dans les médias pour
former les citoyens les sciences et les
mathématiques ne doivent pas être
ervées à une élite mais partagez auprès
du plus grand nombre pour développer
notre pays forger l'esprit critique le
raisonnement factuel et appréhender les
infox et théories complotistes monsieur
le ministre envisagez-vous pour
développer la culture scientifique en
France
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Françoise Ferrat moi aussi je
m'associe à l'hommage qui vient de vous
être chaleureusement rendu et je vous
remercie de votre proposition et me
réjouis qu'elle ait pu rassembler des
sénateurs de tous les bancs sur une
question d'évidence cruciale pour notre
pays nous sommes engagés dans une
stratégie qui vise à promouvoir la
culture scientifique dès le plus jeune
âge afin d'une part de renforcer les
compétences scientifiques des élèves
mais aussi de créer le goût pour les
mathématices et les sciences exactes
avec notamment une priorité celle de
mobiliser les filles dans ces matières
cette stratégie n'aboutira que si nous
déconstruisons des représentations que
les élèves peuvent avoir des
mathématiques qui apparaissent souvent
comme difficiles ou trop élitiste comme
souligne très justement votre résolution
l'excellence scientifique française doit
concerner un plus grand nombre d'élèves
afin de construire leur esprit
scientifique et de lutter contre les
infoges elle doit aussi permettre à
notre économie de pouvoir compter sur
des compétences scientifiques de très
haut niveau qui répondront aux enjeux de
demain en particulier la transition
écologique et la révolution numérique je
voudrais mentionner deux points qui sont
susceptibles d'attirer votre attention
d'une part la création de clubs de
mathématiques dans les collèges la
multiplication de ces clubs de
mathématiques qui favorisent une
pratique collégiale et souvent ludique
des mathématiques sous l'égide du
mathématicien Hugo Dumesnil copain
médaille fiels d'autre part
l'introduction d'une heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun des
élèves de première à compter de la
terminale concernant l'orientation des
fils l'objectif est d'atteindre 50% de
filles dans les principales spécialités
scientifiques de la voix générale à
l'horizon du quinquennat je suis donc
plus que favorable à votre résolution
qui permettra de renforcer encore la
dynamique dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés merci
je vais m'attendre donner la parole à
notre collègue Charles Guénet oui
sénateur de Haute-Marne depuis 2001
investi sur les enjeux des collectivités
territoriales et notamment de la
fiscalité locale il y a un binôme
terrible qui s'appelle Charles
guénet-claude Raynal dans notre histoire
financière de la commission des finances
je n'oublie pas qu'il a été
vice-président de notre institution et
qu'à la commission des finances comme à
la délégation sénatoriale au
collectivités territoriales il a été
engagé et permettez-moi aussi de saluer
le président de l'Amicale des sénateurs
gaullistes du Sénat en le remerciant
tout ce qu'il a apporté au Sénat voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président merci
Michel collègue
simplement je m'écarterai vos marques
dans le président de mon tropisme
collectivités locales je vous ai à cet
égard envoyé mon testament si j'ose dire
hier soir
pour m'intéresser à l'instar de notre
collègue le président requier qui
s'intéresse au retraites je
m'intéresserai à l'état des maisons de
santé ça ne nous étonnera pas
alors Monsieur le Ministre un grand
hebdomadaire publie chaque année depuis
20 ans le classement et le palmarès des
établissements de santé français grâce
aux données d'ailleurs que lui
fournissait jusqu'à lors votre ministère
or ce journal vient de se voir refuser
l'accès aux données dont il bénéficiaire
après la vie d'un organisme dont vous
maîtrisez les nominations pourquoi une
telle remise en cause à un moment où
l'organisation de la santé et des
hôpitaux sur le territoire prête à
critique et où se pose la question de la
transparence pourquoi se priver d'un
avis sur l'état de la santé au plan
national
donc à l'époque du développement de
l'Open Data monsieur le ministre que
pensez-vous de cette situation regarde
des difficultés d'accès à l'information
que rencontre à la fois la presse mais
aussi le Parlement dans certaines
circonstances
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Charles Guénet
merci de me donner l'occasion de
rétablir la vérité dans cette polémique
qui finalement n'en est pas une parce
que répéter à nauséates a fait inexact
n'en fait pas pour autant une vérité
vous serez vous serez d'accord avec moi
alors quelle est cette vérité la loi ots
du 24 juillet 2019
qui a été
voté par le Parlement créer un organisme
indépendant et j'insiste sur le terme
indépendant de contrôle des données de
santé le Cerces pourquoi un organisme
spécifiquement sur les données de santé
parce que vous savez comme moi que les
données de santé sont particulièrement
sensibles et ne peuvent pas être utilisé
n'importe comment ce cercess a émis le 2
juin un avis défavorable quant à la
méthodologie utilisée par ce journal
pour traiter les données de santé
précisant même que cette méthodologie
pouvait avoir des conséquences en termes
d'informations inexactes qui elle-même
et on l'a vu pendant la crise sanitaire
de multiples façons avoir des
conséquences sur la santé même de nos
concitoyens cet avis du cercess a été
confirmé par un avis de la CNIL et je
sais que cette organisme de contrôle
Informatique et Liberté et
particulièrement cher à cette assemblée
et j'ai tout naturellement suivi la vie
des experts comme nous le faisons chaque
fois qu'il y a une question et en
particulier une question sanitaire j'ai
même dès le lendemain de cet avis et
sollicité par ce journal écrit au
rédacteur en chef du journal pour lui
proposer l'aide des services du
ministère afin d'aménager sa
méthodologie et qu'elle puisse répondre
aux exigences légitimes du Cerces et de
la CNIL à ce jour je n'ai pas eu de
réponse à ce courrier qui date
maintenant d'il y a à peu près un an
alors
la vérité elle est là l'effet sont les
faits
oserais-je dire dans cette assemblée
l'effet sont têtus mais en tout cas vous
voyez qu'il témoigne que personne dans
cette affaire ne porte le rôle de
censeur et qu'au contraire dès lors que
les données sont utilisées de façon
pertinente ils sont tout à fait à
disposition de ceux qui veulent les
traiter je vous remercie
oui monsieur le ministre
vous explications bien que confortables
ne sont pas convaincantes parce que je
pense que l'esprit du texte que nous
avons voté en 2019 n'était pas
nécessairement celui-là et on verra
comment
cet instant sabotive je pense que sur le
plan de la méthode et de la philosophie
nous ne pouvons pas être satisfaits
certains pourraient voir une énième
expression d'un pouvoir vertical qui ne
souhaite pas être contesté qui veut
contrôler l'information quand il
n'organise pas des comités théodules
dont il pilote les conclusions et ça
peut dénoter quand même à moelleux une
absence de respect de la démocratie la
pluralité de l'information comme de la
liberté de la presse et notre dans notre
démocratie je crois que tout le monde
sait que la santé nos hôpitaux sont
malades et les Français ne souhaitent
pas qu'on mette en place
qu'on brise ils préfèrent plutôt prendre
adopte des thérapies merci
la parole est à notre collègue Rémi
Féraud pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre coup politique suivi d'une
grande désinvolture sélection des
dossiers bâclés et opaque précipitations
dans les laboration du cahier des
charges comme de l'appel à candidature
fait du prince concernant l'attribution
ou la non attribution de subventions et
finalement un fiasco la commission
d'enquête sanatoriale sur le fond
Marianne sous l'égide de son président
Claude Raynal et de son rapporteur
Jean-François Husson a établi un rapport
accablant si ajoute les conclusions de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration tout aussi sévère les
dysfonctionnements constatés ils sont
d'autant plus graves qu'ils concernent
une politique publique indispensable
celle de la lutte contre la propagande
islamiste et ce n'est pas cet objectif
qui doit être remis en cause c'est son
détournement qui est inacceptable et qui
doit être dénoncé alors madame la
ministre comptez-vous mettre en œuvre
les recommandations établies par la
commission d'enquêtes sénatoriales pour
éviter que de telles dérives ne se
reproduisent et surtout quelles
conséquences politiques le gouvernement
compte-t-il en tirer
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la secrétaire d'État chargée de
la citoyenneté madame Sonia bacchesse
merci
monsieur le sénateur Ferro il me tient
un coeur d'abord que nous restions dans
cette affaire factuelle je veux d'abord
rappeler que le gouvernement a fait
preuve à la fois de réactivité et de
transparence dès les premières
interrogations dans ce dossier
réactivité avec la demande qui a été
faite à l'inspection générale de
l'administration dès les premières
alertes et le signalement sur le
fondement de l'article 40 à la procureur
de la République de Paris sur les mêmes
signalements transparence avec la
transmission et vous le savez bien
monsieur le sénateur au plus vite de
tous les documents qui ont été demandés
par la commission d'enquête du Sénat par
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration et désormais par le
parquet national financier qui a démarré
une enquête qu'il ne m'a pas qu'il ne
m'appartient pas de commenter désormais
il nous faut et vous l'avez dit tirer
les conséquences de ce qui s'est passé
sur ce dossier et des manquements graves
qui ont été constatés à la fois par la
commission d'enquête du Sénat et par la
liaspection générale de l'administration
c'est fait sont inacceptables et ils
nous appartient maintenant de mettre en
œuvre
tout ce qu'il faut pour sécuriser nos
procédures et donc de mettre en oeuvre
l'ensemble des préconisations de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et les recommandations
de la commission d'enquête du Sénat mais
je veux aussi dire qu'il nous appartient
et vous l'avez dit de sécuriser cette
politique publique cette politique
publique de lutte contre les
séparatismes je voudrais rappeler
également que sur les 17 associations
qui ont été lauréates du fond Marianne
15 on fait un travail absolument
remarquable contre ceux qui s'attaquent
à nos valeurs contre ceux qui
considèrent que les lois de la religion
sont supérieures à celles de la
République et pour que ces associations
puissent continuer pour qu'elles
puissent continuer à nous accompagner
dans le combat nous devons les soutenir
et faire la part des choses entre les
manquements aussi graves soient-ils qui
ont été constatés et notre engagement
sur le sujet et je suis convaincue
pardon que vous le que vous le partagez
et que nous devons lutter ensemble
contre ces ennemis de la République je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre nous partageons les
objectifs de lutte contre la propagande
islamiste mais votre réponse n'est pas
convaincante vous parlez de réactivité
et de transparence mais quelles
conséquences politiques tirez-vous de
cette affaire après la révélation du
scandale du fond Marianne la première
ministre avait déjà jugé que se séparer
de la ministre concernée n'était je cite
pas nécessaire pourtant disons-le dans
n'importe quel autre pays européen
madame siapa aurait déjà démissionné du
gouvernement il y a eu dans cette
affaire beaucoup d'irresponsabilités il
est temps de faire prévaloir le principe
de responsabilité politique c'est une
exigence démocratique c'est une exigence
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
les paroles est à notre collègue Pierre
kuppert pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
en place en Seine-et-Marne un
hélicoptère dragon de la direction
générale de la sécurité civile et de la
gestion des crises a été déplacée il
faisait l'objet d'une expérimentation de
délocalisation de la flotte parisienne
depuis 2018
déployée dans un rayon de 100 km il a
suré pour la région Île-de-France et les
départements limitrophes la sécurité de
plus de 15 millions de nos concitoyens
Madame le Ministre quelle est la
politique du gouvernement pour assurer
la continuité d'un service de secours
rapide et efficace en Seine-et-Marne
bien sûr et sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame Faure merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur qui perd
les moyens nationaux sont déployés ou
prépositionner dans les secteurs où ils
sont le plus utile
à savoir les milieux où la présence d'un
hélicoptère apporte une réelle
plus-value soit par des gains de délai
d'intervention soit en raison de
l'inaccessibilité des lieux
d'intervention par des moyens routiers
ou terrestres les milieux montagneux et
côteux et côtiers sont donc privilégiés
les variations saisonnières de
population dans les secteurs
touristiques ont également influer sur
les implantations nous sommes toutes
fois conscients de la nécessité de faire
évoluer notre dispositif en permanence
pour mieux l'adapter aux risques et sans
doute mieux le coordonner avec les
autres moyens aériens dont nous
disposons la gendarmerie ou du Samu la
première ministre a demandé aux députés
Morel à l'huissier de lui rendre un
rapport d'ici fin décembre sur les
conditions d'engagement et des moyens
héliportés nous nous appuierons donc
dessus pour faire évoluer ces
implantations de la manuelle la plus
pertinente et la plus consensuelle
possible s'agissant monsieur le sénateur
plus précisément de l'hélicoptère qui
avait été placé en expérimentation sur
la base de Melun le choix était fait de
le retirer cet appareil compte tenu des
contraintes de disponibilité qui
existent sur l'ensemble de la flotte
nationale pour le placer momentanément à
un autre endroit les moyens
supplémentaires que vous avez adoptés en
loop me font toutefois nous permettre
d'augmenter la disponibilité de ces
engins puisque nous allons renouveler
intégralement la flotte dès que nous
aurons retrouvé notre capacité sans
doute dès le début de l'année prochaine
un hélicoptère sera réaffecté à la base
de Melun l'expérimentation comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur ayant
été concluante je vous remercie monsieur
Kuiper
sincèrement vous semblez ignorer la
situation telle qu'elle est certes le
parc global des hélicoptères de la
sécurité civile en France est légèrement
supérieure à 36 appareils mais cinq se
sont crachés depuis 2003 et aucun n'a
été remplacé deux autres sont cloués au
sol par manque de pièces détachées notez
aussi la défaillance du contrat de
maintien des conditions opérationnelles
la durée des visites de maintenance est
passée de 12 semaines à 22 semaines de
plus la découverte de fissures sur les
queues de 5 appareils les rangs
indisponibles pour l'été 2023 la
dégradation du maintien opérationnel de
la flotte engendre depuis plus de deux
ans des fermetures régulières de base
enfin aucune anticipation n'est réalisé
afin d'externaliser l'entretien compte
tenu des éléments que je viens d'évoquer
alors voilà la réalité madame la
ministre la sécurité civile n'est pas et
ne sera pas au rendez-vous de la saison
estivale 2023 et vous emporterez toute
la responsabilité au détriment de la
sécurité de tous nos concitoyens merci
je vais dernière
question de
cette année parlementaires session
ordinaire et extraordinaire la parole je
vais la donner à Jacques le nez qui lui
aussi
va pris la décision de quitter le Sénat
il a été sénateur du Morbihan c'est
beaucoup investi sur les questions
militaires et internationales au sein de
notre commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées et
tout récemment encore dans l'examen de
la loi de programmation militaire sur
lequel nous allons aboutir je le pense
vice-président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises il amené les
travaux importants notamment sur la
question de la responsabilité sociale
des entreprises je voulais le remercier
au nom du Sénat mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le Président pour vos
propos
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre chargée de la ruralité
madame la ministre avec mes collègues
nous sommes très inquiets sur
l'engagement de nos concitoyens dans les
fonctions électives principalement
locales de nombreux élus locaux
s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur les
conditions d'exercice de leur mandat
mandat qui s'exerce toujours davantage
au détriment de leur famille leur vie
professionnelle leur santé et désormais
leur sécurité notre société s'avère de
plus en plus violente au regard de la
vague inédite de démission environ 1300
maires depuis 2020 il y a fort à parier
que beaucoup d'élus hésiteront à se
représenter en 2026 pour différentes
raisons la brutalité des réseaux sociaux
l'empilement de normes et des procédures
parfois contradictoires des règles
d'urbanisme qui tournent au cauchemar
des citoyens de plus en plus exigeants
une perte d'autonomie malgré des
transferts de charges la liste est
longue les élus sont de plus en plus
pris en étau entre
[Musique]
alors je tiens une nouvelle fois à
réaffirmer tout mon soutien toute ma
solidarité au maire au service
municipaux et aux fortes et aux forces
de l'ordre qui ont été victimes de
violences absolument inexcusables des
émeutiers ces dernières semaines le
gouvernement présentera la semaine
prochaine dans cet enceinte les mesures
d'urgence pour accompagner les maires
dans la reconstruction de nos maisons
communes je partage votre constat depuis
un an je parcours la France des
territoires et celle des mères tous
m'ont fait part d'un épuisement face aux
difficultés qu'ils éprouvaient dans
l'exercice de leur mandat tous m'ont
aussi alerté sur l'absolu nécessité de
travailler sur les conditions d'exercice
du mandat des Luc local et donc de maire
en revanche j'ai aussi vu un engagement
sans limite des mères une ambition forte
de continuer leur mission et une fois
républicaine à toute épreuve il est
certain parce que c'est mon engagement
en tant que ministre parce que c'est ma
conviction d'anciennes élus locales que
nous devons accompagner les maires dans
l'exercice de leur mandat et faciliter
leur quotidien pour continuer à assurer
un service public local et une
démocratie représentative de sens
je change régulièrement avec toutes les
associations d'élus et particulièrement
avec l'AMF et son président David
Lisnard sur ce sujet je vais déjà fait
part de notre intention de créer les
outils nécessaires pour que dans notre
pays les maires puissent mieux vivre
leur mandat et s'épanouir à le réaliser
je tiens à vous assurer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de ma pleine
conscience de la responsabilité qui
m'incombe ainsi que celle des ministres
Gérald Darmanin et Christophe Béchu qui
comme vous le savez sont aussi en
soutien des actions à venir pour les
maires et pour notre démocratie locale
alors nous allons pour reprendre
l'expression de la sénatrice de roche
réenchanter la fonction de maire par un
travail partenarial et concret avec les
associations des lions nous appuyant sur
les nombreux rapports du Sénat et
particulièrement le tout dernier que
vous avez intitulé avis de tempête sur
la démocratie locale et avant la fin de
l'année nous aurons des propositions
concrètes partenariats et partagées à
vous proposer merci
chers collègues allez-y
les élus locaux sont les fondements de
notre démocratie pour leur venir en aide
un choc civique est certes nécessaire à
condition de lui donner de la
consistance pour encourager nos élus à
poursuivre leurs actions pour susciter
de nouvelles vocations ils ont besoin de
reconnaissance de la Nation de mesure
crédibles pour exercer sereinement et
efficacement leur mandat et en fin d'un
soutien sans faille de l'État merci mon
cher collègue
mes chers collègues les prochaines
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
auront lieu le mercredi 11 octobre mais
je ne vais pas lever la séance sans
rendre hommage à une présidente de
groupe qui a beaucoup apporté au Sénat
je veux rendre hommage à la présidente
Eliane assassy qui préside le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
[Applaudissements]
elle a été la sénatrice de l'année 2022
mais avec ces convictions avec son
engagement avec si elle représente son
attachement à la République et cette
forme d'attention aux autres au plus
modestes et au plus pauvre elle incarne
vraiment à la fois la famille politique
à laquelle elle est tellement attachée
mais aussi une richesse pour notre Sénat
et pour notre République je voulais la
remercier personnellement
nous reprendrons notre séance à 16
heures 35 pour l'examen des conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire visant
à renforcer la protection des familles
d'enfants atteint d'une maladie ou d'un
handicap aux victimes d'un accident la
séance des suspendus Joël remercier
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs leurs ministres et madame la
Première ministre particulièrement je
l'ai fait à une autre occasion pour sa
présence constante avec le ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
aux questions au gouvernement au Sénat
la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]